We want to test the hypothesis
that more than 30% of U.S.
households have internet access
with a significance
level of 5%.
We collect a sample of 150
households, and find that 57
have access.
So to do our hypothesis test,
let's just establish our null
hypothesis and our alternative
hypothesis.
So our null hypothesis is that
the hypothesis is not correct.
Our null hypothesis is that
the proportion of U.S.
households that have internet
access is less
than or equal to 30%.
And our alternative hypothesis,
is what our
hypothesis actually is, is
that the proportion is
greater than 30%.
We see it over here.
We want to test the hypothesis
that more than 30% of U.S.
households have internet
access.
That's that right here.
This is what we're testing.
We're testing the alternative
hypothesis.
And the way we're going to do it
is we're going to assume a
P-value based on the
null hypothesis.
We're going to assume a
proportion based on the null
hypothesis for the population.
And the given that assumption,
what is the probability that
57 out of 150 of our samples
actually have internet access.
And if that probability is less
than 5%, if it's less
than our significance level,
then we're going to reject the
null hypothesis in favor
of the alternative one.
So let's think about
this a little bit.
So we're going to start off
assuming-- we're going to
assume the null hypothesis
is true.
And in that assumption we're
going to have to pick a
population proportion or a
population mean-- we know that
for Bernoulli distributions
do the same thing.
And what I'm going to do is I'm
going to pick a proportion
so high so that it maximizes
the probability of getting
this over here.
And we actually don't even
know what that number is.
And actually so that we can
think about a little more
intelligent, let's just find
out what our sample
proportion even is.
We had 57 people out of 150
having internet access.
So 57 households out of 150.
So our sample proportion
is 0.38, so let me
write that over here.
Our sample proportion
is equal to 0.38.
So when we assume our null
hypothesis to be true, we're
going to assume a population
proportion that maximizes the
probability that we get
this over here.
So the highest population
proportion that's within our
null hypothesis that will
maximize the probability of
getting this is actually
if we are right at 30%.
So if we say our population
proportion, we're going to
assume this is true.
This is our null hypothesis.
We're going to assume that
it is 0.3 or 30%.
And I want you understand that--
29% would have been a
null hypothesis.
28% that would have been
a null hypothesis.
But for 29% or 28%, the
probability of getting this
would have been even lower.
So it wouldn't have been
as strong of a test.
If we take the maximum
proportion that still
satisfies our null hypothesis,
we're maximizing the
probability that we get this.
So if that number is still low,
if it's still less than
5%, we can feel pretty good
about the alternative
hypothesis.
So just to refresh ourselves
we're going to assume a
population proportion of 0.3,
and if we just think about the
distribution-- sometimes it's
helpful to draw these things,
so I will draw it.
So this is what the population
distribution looks like based
on our assumption,
based on this
assumption right over here.
Our population distribution
has-- or maybe I should write
30% have internet access.
And I'll signify
that with a 1.
And then the rest don't
have internet access.
70% do not have internet
access.
This is just a Bernoulli
distribution.
We know that the mean over here
is going to be the same
thing as the proportion that
has internet access.
So the mean over here is going
to be 0.3, same thing as 30%.
This is the population mean.
And maybe I should
write this way.
The mean assuming our null
hypothesis, the population
mean assuming our null
hypothesis is 0.3.
And then the population
standard deviation.
Let me write this over
here in yellow.
The population standard
deviation assuming our null
hypothesis.
And we've seen this when we
first learned about Bernoulli
distributions.
It is going to be the square
root of the percentage of the
population that has internet
access, so 0.3 times the
proportion of the population
that does not have internet
access, times 0.7
right over here.
So this is the square
root of 0.21.
And we could deal with this
later using our calculator.
Now, with that out of the way,
we want to figure out the
probability of getting a sample
proportion that has a 0.38.
So let's look at the
distribution of sample
proportions.
So you could literally look at
every combination of getting
150 households from this, and
you would actually get a
binomial distribution.
And we've also seen
this before.
You would actually get a
binomial distribution where
you'd get a bunch of
bars like that.
But if your n is suitably large,
and in particular-- and
this is kind of the test for
it-- the test if n times p--
and in this case we're saying
p is 30%-- if n times p is
greater than 5, and n times 1
minus p is greater than 5, you
can assume that the distribution
of the sample
proportion or the sample
proportion distribution is
going to be normal.
So if you looked at all of the
different ways you could
sample 150 households from this
population, you get all
of these bars.
But since our n is pretty big,
it's 150, and 150 times 0.3 is
obviously greater than 5.
150 times 0.7 is also
greater than 5.
You can approximate that with
a normal distribution.
So let me do that.
So you can approximate it with
a normal distribution.
So this is a normal distribution
right over there.
Now the mean of the distribution
of the proportion
data that we're assuming is a
normal distribution is going
to be-- and remember, working
under the context that the
null hypothesis is true.
So this mean is going to be--
this mean right here-- so the
mean of our sample proportions
is going to be the same thing
as our population mean.
So this is going to be 0.3,
same value as that.
And the standard deviation---
this comes straight from the
central limit theorem.
So the standard deviation of
our sample proportions, the
standard deviation is going to
be the square root-- let me
put it this way-- it's going to
be our population standard
deviation, the standard
deviation we're assuming with
our null hypothesis divided by
the square root of the number
of samples we have. And in this
case we have 150 samples.
It's going to be 150 samples
and we can calculate this.
This value on top we just
figured out is the
square root of 0.21.
So this is the square root
of 0.21 over the
square root of 150.
And I can get the calculator
out to calculate this.
So I'll just do it the
way I wrote it.
The square root of 0.21-- and
I'm going to divide that, so
whatever answer is I'm going to
divide that by the square
root of 150.
So it's 0.037.
So we figured out the standard
deviation here of our-- or the
distribution of our sample
proportions is going to be--
let me write this down, I'll
scroll over to the right a
little bit-- it is 0.037.
I think I'm falling off the
screen a little bit.
So we'll just say 0.037.
Now to figure out the
probability of having a sample
proportion of 0.38, we just have
to figure out how many
standard deviations that is
away from our mean, or
essentially calculate a
Z-statistic for our sample,
because a Z-statistic or a
Z-score is really just how
many standard deviations you
are away from the mean.
And then figure out whether
the probability of getting
that Z-statistic is more
or less than 5%.
So let's figure out how many
standard deviations we are
away from the mean.
So just remind ourselves, this
sample proportion we got we
can view as just a sample from
this distribution of all of
the possible sample
proportions.
So how many standard
deviations away
from the mean is this?
So if we take our sample
proportion, subtract from that
the mean of the distribution
of sample proportions and
divide it by the standard
deviation of the distribution
of the sample proportions, we
get 0.38, 0.38 minus 0.3.
All of that over this
value which we just
figured out was 0.037.
So what does that give us?
The numerator over
here is a 0.08.
The denominator is 0.037.
So let's figure this out.
So our numerator is 0.08 divided
by this last number
right here, which
is the 0.037.
So second answer and we get
2.1-- I'll just round it to
2.14 standard deviations.
So this is equal to-- this right
here is equal to 2.14
standard deviations.
Or we could say that our
Z-statistic, right, we could
call this our Z-score or our
Z-statistic, the number of
standard deviations we are away
from our mean is 2.14.
We're at 2.14, and to be exact,
we're 2.14 standard
deviations above the mean.
We're going to care about a
one-tailed distribution.
Now is the probability
of getting this more
or less than 5%?
If it's less than 5% we're
going to reject the null
hypothesis in favor of
our alternative.
So how do we think about that?
Well let's think about just
a normalized normal
distribution.
Or maybe you could call the
Z-distribution if you want.
If you look at a normal
distribution, a completely
normalized normal distribution,
it's mean is at 0.
And essentially each
of these values
are essentially Z-scores.
Because a value of 1 literally
means you are 1 standard
deviation away from this
mean over here.
So we need to find a critical
Z-value right over here.
Let me call that a critical Z--
we could even say critical
Z-score or critical Z-value--
so that the probability of
getting a Z-value higher
than that is 5%.
So that this whole area
right here is 5%.
And that's because that's what
our significance level is.
Anything that has a lower than
5% a chance of occurring, for
us will be validation to reject
our null hypothesis.
Or another way of thinking about
it is that area's 5%,
this whole area right
over here is 95%.
And once again, this is a
one-tailed test, because we
only care about values
greater than this.
Z-values greater than that will
make us reject the null
hypothesis.
And to figure out this critical
Z-value you can
literally just go
to a Z-table.
And we say OK, the probability
of being a Z-value less than
that is 95%.
And that's exactly the number
that this gives us.
The cumulative probability
of getting a
value less than that.
So if we just scan this,
we're looking for 95%.
We have 0.9495, we
have 0.9505.
So I'll go with this just
to make sure we're
a little bit closer.
So this Z-value, and the z-value
here is 1.6, and the
next digit is 5.
1.6 5.
So this critical Z-value
is equal to 1.65.
So the probability of getting
a Z-value less than 1.65, or
even in a completely
normalized normal
distribution, the probability
of getting a
value less than 1.65.
Or in any normal distribution,
the probability of being less
than 1.65 standard deviations
away from the mean
is going to be 95%.
So that's our critical
Z-value.
Now does Z-value, or the
Z-statistic, for our actual
sample is 2.14.
Our actual Z-value
we got is 2.14.
It's sitting all the way
out here some place.
So the probability of
getting that was
definitely less than 5%.
And actually we could even say
what's the probability of
getting that or a more
extreme result.
And if you figured out this
area, and you could actually
figure it out by looking at a
Z-table, you could figure out
the P-value of this result.
But anyway, the whole exercise
here is just to figure out if
can reject the null hypothesis
with a significance level 5%.
We can.
This is a more extreme result
than our critical Z-value, so
we can reject the null
hypothesis in favor of our
alternative.